hello and welcome to this video playing
black against come day long candle isn't
that something isn't that something
isn't that something related to light
some light measurement or something kind
of reminds us of candle yeah probably
yeah this is actually an interesting
line I think for white me not something
that will blow black out of the water
quickly but it is quite playable and not
class explored as an annoyance I tend to
miss play that it's just in it
I really tend to miss play this stuff
and I always dislike if they take on c6
or so I'm going to use seven
[Music]
you
[Music]
uh-huh yeah that is true
it's actually very true
yeah okay
have to take should takes no tags
should so be okay I believe in 94 should
still be fine
all right now how do we play this
pollution interesting
[Music]
maybe just f60 get rid of the e5 pawn
[Music]
oops
seven for sure
you
what has to be a little bit careful the
Queen can be can be a liability
you
hmm
I don't mind dad looks quite ok him
so just see six on I don't know
we should know
should be five is never never an idea
see six is just a move that I need to
play at some point here the bishop wants
to go to c7 probably anyway and it
covers everything so good to pawn chain
a move that I always have available here
is going to c8 forcing the Queen trade
the resulting position is definitely
noise for black I just have the better
pawn structure but it is not it's
nothing
grade why is that a move look aged six
okay age six
you
really odd
Queen f5 or what is the thing yeah
that's really weird
maybe Queen f5 is a move
you
I see em in India Bishop g5 sorry 95
Bishop g5
is
cannot make that work remarkable
you
[ __ ] 7s Knight takes e4
interesting
hmm very odd very odd
here I'm slightly afraid that murukku
can get trapped I would be able to be a
would be really funky 96 and then what
yeah
I think I think it cannot be trapped
you
no it was not possible to trap it m94
though he am that's interesting
should therefore it's not a really great
move
okay
[Music]
you
hmm I cannot do much
this kind of remarkable
[Music]
you
you
just want to prevent
the night um my I didn't manage to
prevent it entirely
you
Wow I doesn't work
each form
interesting
the king boxed in and it is slowly I
could have I could have just taken on b2
[Music]
and still lots of things hanging okay
now okay let's go for the rook ending it
will win quite easily
right so when let's have a look at I was
a bit odd
this middle game so I always am annoyed
by why taking on c6 this is why I played
97 but I don't think it is such a
convincing way of playing actually
Bishop d3 Bishop a5
Quincy true
and here maybe just taking hiriam
I've had this kind of stuff on the board
in blitz chess and I was never
completely convinced that it is so great
for me a four for example I know this is
just not good the computer I'm still
thinks I'm fine but yeah you know I'm
not a fan so this happened Queen takes
94 castles f66 looks normal for me
the computer wants to go a for him
it's an interesting idea
probably it wants to play like a five or
something here No
I know what a four is doing then if you
are not going to follow up with a fire
okay he captured rook takes Queen age 3c
695 and he are wondering at what what
what a good solution is because Queen f6
is kind of
six well no I didn't think of that
I like this more but I mean this is okay
but I didn't think
I wasn't so happy with this and now a
night of three @t indeed seems to be
good for white
and the issue is if this is this idea
all of a some
and they have this odd look that's
really odd
I should call 96a I didn't see the move
at all I was probably too much
yeah okay so this one page 43
I don't think g3 is great I'm happy to
return to to the square anyway
and somehow hey I think I missed
something I must have missed something
Brooke FHM in one move is better I
realized that a little bit later but I
can't hear I didn't quite see much after
307
oh sure before g5n on i-295 is a blunder
it should be six is still very okay for
white
now here we were both fit down down with
the time
so here it's kind of okay nothing
special
yeah okay Knight e5 and here I'm winning
I should probably take on between but in
here in particular I should just take
here threatening look I have to add will
be killing immediately but okay it's
already pretty large advantage misses
again it's it's it's simple but it wins
have the rook ending so is an easy easy
enough win okay guys thanks for watching